-Our next guest is the host of
"The Ali Kolbert Show,"
available at Apple Podcasts.
Please welcome the very funny
Ali Kolbert!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hi, you guys! Oh, my God.
It is so good to be back on
"The Tonight Show"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I just got my booster,
so I can finally see
my family this Thanksgiving!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, not the shot, the seat.
I'm leaving the kids table.
I finally get to be at eyeline.
I am fun-sized, so I get hit on
by a lot of young dudes.
Like 10-year-old boys
coming up to me being like,
"What's your
favorite color, mama?"
I was at the grocery store
the other day with my friend.
And my friend is my age, but she
looks like an adult human woman.
And this little boy goes up
to her and he says,
"Excuse me, miss.
I really like your daughter."
I was like,
"Dude, how old are you?
Do you even have an allowance?"
He was like,
"Yeah, I have an allowance."
So, going to his Little League
game tomorrow.
Go, Rangers!
I figured this out --
that there's two types of men
in the world, okay?
There's a nice guy
and a shady guy.
And your nice guy
is Amazon, okay?
Your shady guy is USPS.
Amazon's always hitting you up
with updates --
"I'll be right there."
USPS, you're like,
"Hey, where are you?"
And he's just like,
"Somewhere in New Jersey, baby."
I'm like, "I thought you were
coming over."
He's like, "Stay home between
12:00 and 6:00.
Maybe I'll swing by."
Amazon's super-excited.
He comes immediately.
He's like,
"How was that for you?"
USPS is like, "Yo, can I leave
my package unprotected?"
I think dudes
talk a big game, you know?
They're like,
"Let me take you out."
I'm like, "You don't know what
a top sheet is, Connor.
We're not going out.
You own one towel."
I've met guys who swear they
have two towels.
They have one towel
that's ripped in half.
That is not two.
I feel like the sexism in
this country's out of control.
Like, a dude hooks up with a ton
of women, "Oh, he's a player."
I hook up with a ton of women,
"Oh, lesbian!"
Not cool.
I did get a girlfriend
over the pandemic.
And these girlfriends --
they ask a lot of questions.
My girlfriend's
got a lot of questions.
She wants to have a baby.
She's like,
"Who's going to carry?
Who's doing IVF?
Whose sperm are we using?"
I'm like, "I got a question.
Who's doing this with you, okay?
'Cause I'm out. No deal."
That's how I talk now
that I've seen
every single episode of
"Shark Tank."
I'm like, "I'll never
make my money back
on a toddler, sweetheart.
I'm out.
No deal."
I think it's interesting how
you figure out your sexuality.
Like, when I was younger,
we would play spin the bottle.
And if a girl spun the bottle
and it landed on
another girl, everyone would be
like, "Oh, redo."
And I'd always be like,
"Stick to the rules, okay?!
I respect the integrity
of this game!
Pucker up, Jenna!"
And, like, I was in
a sorority in college.
That's quite the conundrum --
to be a lesbian in a sorority,
'cause everyone's just like,
"We are sisters!"
And I'm like, "Not by blood!"
"We can still do stuff.
I didn't join this for family!"
Thank you so much.
I'm Ali Kolbert!
♪♪
Thank you, guys.
-Ah! I love...
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God.
Oh, Ali Kolbert!
Ali Kolbert!
"The Ali Kolbert show"
is available at Apple Podcasts.